[Applaudissements]
tous les mercredis c'est les quatre airs
de jean luc lemoine en compagnie je
voulais ni d'agathe lecaron et de kamel
le magicien montjean lui qui a dû pour
cette semaine
oui parce qu'on a eu une invitée
particulier afida turner un bon cela nos
valeurs je vais déjeuner qui se croisent
vous jure que c'est vrai mais bon c'est
bien vous avez dansé et on était dans un
restaurant c'était pas un thé dansant
non plus ses blessures mais dès ce vous
danser aussi donc c'est vrai ça qui vous
arrête une émission de divertissement
d'humeur voilà bonsoir vous êtes venus
ça oui bonsoir merci d'être passé vous
êtes là la semaine prochaine bonjour je
m'appelle nadine la semaine dernière
vous avez reçu afida turner dans votre
émission
donc je voulais savoir est ce que vous
comptez faire ça souvent qu'à moi ça m'a
fait imploser matelly allait pas les
gens là vous la connaissez vous avez
fait l'offre de et elle est à l'époque
elle s'appelle elle s'appelle afida
turner à l'époque elle s'appelait
geneviève pour toi mais je comprends
votre question chez nadine mais je vous
rassure c'est un événement qui se
produit rarement
oui on sert à la fida vient tous les 5 6
ans pour laisser à nos yeux le ton se
reposer bon là c'était jeudi
et dès son entrée on se dit qu'elles
étaient différentes 1 afida c'est la
seule fille qui le 15 février
quant à se croiser quelqu'un ait dit ça
bonjour
[Musique]
à l'aller
je suis présentement jamais
mon épouse
[Musique]
l'eau
le haut
toujours vivant froid sur mes guiboles
toujours debout et je vais faire un gros
bisou à rothau voilà qui est et qui est
évident que j'ai vu là il ya deux
semaines et à qui je fais dodo gros gros
gros bisous voilà on m'annonce était en
relation en plus il a raison maxime elle
doit avoir mal au pana c'est vrai
puisque des talents d'où ça fait bobo et
nos gars là des expressions 10 962 quoi
oui encore vous êtes gentils oui c'est
vrai en tout cas inquiétez pas bien la
semaine dernière c'était jean-michel
chanteau quand il a appris qu'il était
assis à côté
[Musique]
la cour
et
sinon
[Applaudissements]
et
la terre
la tête que je fais après au bout de 10
h au bout de ma vie j'ai quand même
vérifier parce que je me connais moins
en technologie que jean-michel même s'il
est déçu disant tu les as ni chanter
font ça n'existe pas non en fait c'était
pas du tout pour ça le coussin on aurait
préféré ne pas savoir pourquoi
mais cet idiot il s'est senti obligé de
demander vous noterez au passage de
adacore à la fin comme si tout était
normal
je dise
[Applaudissements]
ça glisse un pas qu'ils en mettent aux
jeux olympiques pour le boeuf mais en
fait vous avez bip et le camp ses écrits
mais pas qu'on s'est dit ben non parce
que sinon on comprendrait rien on a eu
un peu de pudeur on a vidé des petits as
tu veux alors si reed aussi était pas
bien ce soir là il fait le malin là mais
j'ai pas comment était ce midi au
restaurant vous allez voir pendant
l'émission il rigolé mais en même temps
on sentait qu'il aurait bien voulu car
une petite distance de sécurité
le fida donc à chaque fois qu'ils
s'approchaient il est un petit pas de
rugby ça quand même petit chaton
effrayer bien essayé et comme ça n'a pas
marché à la fin il a fermé les yeux pour
oublier
[Applaudissements]
g bâle et tour si li na s'est jamais
seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'à la bad est sur moi mais
ce que j'aime c'est pour fermer les yeux
comme si ce sera plus là depuis un
moment sympa vous rappelez cyril à
craquer ah oui afida voulait envoyer un
message de soutien enfin un message
perso à son ami johnny hallyday une
lettre près tout a dérapé et johnny je
sais que nous entende de l'autre n'a je
suis très spirituelle et j'espère que
tes enfants seront pas laissés dans
dénouement à love john une lettre pour
être présent à mon anniversaire à los
angeles est vraiment j'espère qu'on va
tous applaudir johnny
[Applaudissements]
le dénuement
excusez-moi j'ai quand même un
basketteur vous savez revoir sa douleur
[Applaudissements]
à la bactéries mais problème c'est
qu'elle n'avait pas mené ce jour là en
même temps dénouement dénuement quand tu
es en jet lag ça ça peut se comprendre
comme on peut comprendre que tu prennes
tout premier degré là vous allez voir
pendant la chronique de camille combal
afida vraiment que jean pierre pernaut
était chaud et ça l'a rendu très triste
mais en vrai way jean pierre pernaut il
a décidé de parler à crâne découvert
il faut l'aimer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est charmante parce que si on va
pas ressasser derniers jours il ya eu le
scandale des conférences de laurent
wauquiez vous savez pas et mieux que ça
t la conversation privée de maxime
gainey et quévy vdev dit on va entendre
les grands beaux du type saperlipopette
un document explosif la voûte et ds que
peuvent se raconter de jeunes aux
adultes attirés l'un par l'autre
avec la tension érotique on imagine sur
les plateaux télé d'ailleurs on veut
savoir un moment ce qui se voit là vous
allez savoir ce jour-là qu'il était
déguisé en lapin à
la gribouille je vais garder rose en a
envoyé justin
histoire
mieux
à y redire
là j'en connais un qui n'est pas près de
sortir sa cagoule
c'est râpé pour lui raté son tir frappé
pour la ses calembours à toute berzingue
non mais vous avez raison par de trop
loin ils n'iront jamais allez on passe
au top chez danse et ça va vous
surprendre mais j'ai encore dû afida
hoya du afida honnêtement
le maire vous rentrez pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alain 10 août la france fait
tu fais temps parce que je sais que tu
esthéticienne no way
et puis la mayo question je dis pas ça
parce que c'est mon ami mais mention
particulière à benjamin castaldi qui est
un très très grand animateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce cas n'est pas tout sa compétence est
bien sûr tout est ensuite
super
germany porsche
pas du tout
ça marche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi je me sens pas bien mais lui
l'estonie m'étais pas bien ça me met
vraiment pana c'est la seule qui peut
vous dire mais moi je suis co focus est
beaucoup trop focus à la save à agathe a
mais là je sais pas si j'ai pas c'est de
l'or en barre à garde la tête de
benjamin castaldi
c'est pourquoi vous avez choisi ce
moment pour le féliciter
la teranga c'est une rendre compte en
fait mal
[Applaudissements]
franchement aujourd'hui que c'est du
bonheur encore on a d'autres qui touche
3 ballons quand il régale ses comptes
quand on est donc sur un truc on se
régale et en plus la régie me dicte à
très bien ta chronique c'est très bien
travaillé par contre moi la régie me dit
vous pouvez vous offrir tout ça concerne
la prochaine voilà est-ce que vous aviez
aimé les petits secrets de fabrication
de tpm paix s'est décantée qu'à petites
histoires qui se cachent derrière une
image diffusée à l'antenne nador et ben
j'en ai une autre a toujours là mathieu
avait sorti une bonne vanne à miss
france 2010 8
maeva couple avait une soeur jumelle
alizés qui est mannequin
oui à dieu bénisse la famille après
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur jumelles palliser qui est mannequin
oui bon dieu bénisse la famille après
elle n'est pas un frère
[Applaudissements]
il est tellement c'est abandonner les
vols il donne un marchand de bonheur si
les abeilles peur il y en a trop et
officiels officiel tu enfiles un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous comprenez pourquoi mathieu se
repose sur jean-michel chute en plus
c'est juste par paresse parce que
franchement toute honnêteté il n'a pas
besoin du tout mathieu vous prouver tout
de suite un cours magistral de mathieu
sur ce qu'est la répartie hachette dar k
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
car ce cas on va faire du moment
également c'est évidemment l'héritage de
johnny hallyday arrivant on a eu
beaucoup de spécialistes en plateau pour
nous en parler et pour prendre un peu de
hauteur je me suis dit que ça serait
intéressant d'avoir un témoignage
discordants de quelqu'un qui n'est pas
choqué qu'on donne rien ses enfants
enfin tant qu'on a donné l'essentiel
voici l'analyse de la faire par jean
michel foulon
[Musique]
dans la grosse étape
jean-luc on a encore des choses qui
arrivent
malheureusement oui malheureusement vie
et on va vous donner un peu plus vous
mais quand même on pas les 4 on commence
par la tête magique de clovis cornillac
sur le plateau alors savoir comme c'est
un garçon poli disait rien et dans son
regard on voyait bien qu'ils se
demandaient où il avait atterri
[Musique]
mais oui le secoue mathieu laveau près
d'un scoop jusque sur les pv n'ont pas
là dessus sur l'émission chaque fois
qu'il a déjà pété d'avoir à transit
impeccable parce qu'il n'est pas au dos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez déjà fait un truc avec des
déguisements
oui il fait en fait ferrer s'est aussi
dit non elle va peut-être venir demain
parce que l enseigne un suivi est là
elle avait un petit peu peur de voilà
mais qui voit là parce que voilà mais
elle va peut-être venir demain ok en
corée du nord
c'est contre les communautés y alors via
l'europe de gens je ne voudrais pas que
les gens pensent que je suis ça ce qui
est totalement faux
en revanche manifestement n'a pas vu les
muscles elle a retenu deux mois c'est
son choix mais en revanche
ma place pour toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais chez moi on va jamais ressentir
encore
pour moi le maître covoiture d'y aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin des deux hôtels etc
gentil maxi
[Applaudissements]
parce que je suis un all in il pense qu
on jamais nous chercher là bas
image de jeune fille
[Musique]
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le diplôme que john valley
de galles elle égale les séries